WITH AKNOB COVID-RELATED
ILLNESS..
BARZAL BETWEEN HIS SKATES.
AND HOW WIDE OPEN
MATT BARZAL IS, SO WIDE OPEN HE
CAN PULL THAT MOVE BETWEEN HISI.
>> A.J.: THE WHISTLE BLEW AND NO
ONE MOVED ON THE BENCH.
I WOULD HAVE ASSUMED.HIGH HERE'
WRIST SHOT BLOCKER.
SAVE, REBOUND, UP.
GIBSON LOOKS LIKE HELUTTERBUCK T
HERE HE GOES DOWN.
HE'S NOT ABLE TO STA FOWLER
CAME RIGHT TO PAGEAU.
THAT PASS DEFLECTED.
WINDS UP BACK ON PALMIERI'S
STICK AND EACH OTHER.
PAGEAU COMES THROUGH AND THEN I.
>> Brendan: AT FIRST GLANCE IT
LOOKED LIKE IT BOUNCED BS.
THEY KNOW GETTING A GOAL IN THE
LAST MINUTE IS HUGE.
HOW ABOUT
REGROUP.
FOWLER'S PASS WAS TO
PICKING UP.
HE CORRALS THESE PLAYERS ARE SK
ENOUGH TO DO IT.
BUT ACTUALLY DOING IT UNLOCKS
THINGS.
SOROKIN MAKESES BY ANAHEIM.
DRYSDALE'S PASS OVER FOR
LINDHOLM. TIP UP AND
IN THE TAN.
>> A.J.: HE ALWAYS HAS MORE IN
THE TANK ONE UP IN THE AIR, GLO
DOWN BY LEE, TAKEN BY TERRY.
THREE ON TWO IF THEY THEY SCORE!
KYLE PALMIERI, HISE TAKES IT DE.
AND HE OFF THE FIRST
ONE.
RIGHT THERE HIS RIG IN THE POWE.
PARISE HAS HIS FACE.
>> Brendan: ALMOST 5-2.
EAD.
PRESSURED.
ZEGRAS.
NOW COMTOIS.
AROUND TO THE FAR SIDE
SHATTENKIRK.
PARI ONE ON ONE
AGAINST THE GOALIE.
THEY SCORE!
THE SAVE BY SOROKIKIBER 3
PULLED OUT HIGH AND THEN IT'S
TERRY WHO'S ABLE TO WALK